Nancy Rios: here.
Nancy Rios: Okay, so, this is gonna be the agenda for today. Today's plan,
Nancy Rios: This is our agenda. We're gonna start with, framing.
Nancy Rios: of the program, and what is driving it. We're gonna connect with each other, here in breakout rooms. We're gonna do an activity also in partnering with, with AI,
Nancy Rios: And we're gonna do hands-on, time with the dojo that was just created for you all, and, wrap up our conversation and, give you guys the next steps for,
Nancy Rios: For next week's, work and what's next. So, yeah, we are gonna be pretty, tight and, on time, so…
Nancy Rios: We'll go ahead and, move on here.
Nancy Rios: So,
Nancy Rios: So yeah, so this is how it works. We will connect once… once a week. This is a Monday session that you guys chose, and whatever you do work on, you will be uploading… uploading everything on Canvas.
Nancy Rios: We do ask that of you, is that you just basically show up and,
Nancy Rios: keep your work intentional. Like, we want to make sure that you guys are able to get
Nancy Rios: the best value during this learning experience, the work that we will be asking you to do, will not be just something that you can check off a box, and then kind of never revisit it again. So we want to make sure that you guys are able to,
Nancy Rios: Utilize your skills and sharpen those skills,
Nancy Rios: you don't receive a grade for anything that you are completing. So, yeah, everything…
Nancy Rios: that we are doing, there's a reason behind it. And yeah, like, nothing in the program is busy work. If something just doesn't feel right, or doesn't feel like it's of value of use,
Nancy Rios: please let us know. We want to make sure that you guys are truly taking ownership of this experience, because this experience is for you guys.
Nancy Rios: Any of the… any questions that you do have, which I have seen in the chat, during, Friday and… and even today, you guys were able to ask questions. Questions, go on Slack. We do prefer it that way, because emails can get messy, and you might have the same question that, maybe someone else might have.
Nancy Rios: And, yeah, it can get resolved, in the chat. So, building community as that, as,
Nancy Rios: as that as well. So, yeah, any questions with anything?
Nancy Rios: Satya, I don't know if you would like to add up on anything.